okay so it's time to hashtag make a
scene at the cosmopolitan of las vegas
yeah you were invited to help the hotel
celebrate its 10-year anniversary
with a special photo tour and of course
cocktail
well rocky theaters is there live to
show us more rocky
hey you guys yeah come closer i have a
secret to tell you
did you know that there is an off the
menu secret cocktail at the chandelier
bar at the cosmopolitan of las vegas
and it includes some magical flowers
alright so i'm going to send it over to
rachel to explain
the drink and the flower but before we
get to that you mentioned a photo tour
so i want to give you the details about
that so if whether you're a tourist
or you're a local you can come on down
all year long to the cosmopolitan to
celebrate the decade of mischief
you get food packages cocktail packages
room
deals too and then of course the photo
tour is called the rose tour
and your guide candidate mischief maker
rose
who all you got to do is text her at hi
rose that's 447673
and then she texts you and you and sends
you to each of the photo
opportunity installations so if you're
seeing those pictures they're really
cute
don't want to miss it all year round and
beyond as well so now let's get to the
verbena okay the secret drink
rachel what is this magical potion i
should call it
it is a slightly asian uh margarita a
twist on a margarita
which may just which makes it special is
the buzz button
the buzz button it's a sichuan button so
when you taste it um it actually makes
your
mouth buzz almost a numbing sensation do
you hear that
so when you take a sip of your drink
okay yeah i'm gonna go ahead and taste
sip it first
okay taste the cocktail and then you
taste like a regular margarita that's
good
flour swish it around a little bit it
doesn't taste great
it never tastes good i never get used i
never get used to that okay
and then afterwards you sip again again
and it changes the flavor
profile of the cocktail and now it's
like a bitter
i don't even know how to describe it
what are those flavors i'm tasting uh
the yuzu is a lot of that
it's the asian inspired yuzu sour
tequila changes its flavor as well
i have to admit it's regular margarita
style and then it turns into something
completely completely different and
delicious so you guys have to come down
to the chandelier bar
to taste the verbena and it's not on the
menu but also there's
a ton of other drinks on the menu that
are classic
that you can enjoy here at the
cosmopolitan because you know it's ten
years
after we've got to be traditional too
yeah so let's talk about the cosmo
the cosmo has been with us all ten years
that we've been open
uh it's our signature foxtail they
they went through many many recipes
before they decided on this one
with the hanger mandarin in the salerno
is his main
some lemon cranberry all and the white
cranberry kind of a different take on
the cosmopolitan
beautiful look at that look at that now
guys they've they've sold over
almost a million of the verbena so i
think it's a fan favorite
it is so come on down celebrate 10 years
of mischief here at the cosmopolitan
i'll send it back to you
i need to start hanging out with rocky
more she knows all the good spots